[Musique]
dans mon bureau devant vague devant ma
bibliothèque
belle didier était oui ça fait un joli
décor
bonjour serge stg c'est la question de
la mort et du deuil qui sont
complètement bouleversé dans cette crise
sanitaire que l'on va aborder avec vous
les rites les cérémonies les hommages
après comment les réinventer d'abord la
france a été donc un temps ce pays qui
n'a pas permis à la fois d'enterrer ses
mort dignement et d'accompagner ces
malades en fin de vie vous le
psychanalyste et le psychiatre est aussi
l'homme que vous êtes n'a jamais accepté
cette décision pourquoi d'abord je n'ai
pas accepté sur un plan personnel parce
que j'avais moi même une vieille maman
nepad qui a été touchée par le par le
virus donc j'ai vécu personnellement ce
que pour lui être ce drame ce que
pouvait être le drame du confinement des
personnes âgées avec qui on n'avait plus
de contact depuis des semaines alors que
j'avais des contacts quasiment
quotidiens avec quel est le drame
d'apprendre qu'elle est malade sans
avoir la possibilité d'aller la voir
heureusement j'ai pu user moi de mon
statut de mes prérogatives de médecins
pour passer les dernières heures avec
elle et je me suis rendu compte à quel
point c'était important à quel point
finalement
c'était de l'ordre de notre humanité de
l'ordre de la dignité de nos sociétés
d'accompagner nos parents nos grands
parents jusqu'à la fin de leur vie comme
ils nous ont accueillis quand quand nous
sommes venus au monde et j'ai mesuré la
la au fond la folie dans laquelle on
était avec ce virus c'est à dire c'est
comme si la peur que cette épidémie a
provoqué on peut le comprendre nous
avait fait perdre tous les cadres
normaux de ce que sont les rapports
humains et de ce conte sont les rapports
dans une famille bien sûr faut prendre
des précautions bien sûr il faut mettre
des masques il faut la distanciation il
faut prendre toutes les précautions
nécessaires
mais couper complètement les liens avec
nos parents c'est c'est c'est de la
démence cette question de
l'accompagnement du dernier adieu de lui
tim présence elle dépasse largement la
question des endeuillés elle est de
l'ordre de notre civilisation c'est
toute notre civilisation il n'y a pas
une seule civilisation digne d'être
appelé civilisation qui n'a pas inventé
tous et tous ces cultes et ses rituels
autour de la fin de vie et tout cet
accompagnement des morts c'est ça fait
vraiment partie de notre dignité de
l'être humain c'est le lien qui nous qui
nous relient c'est ce seuil la cet
accompagnement entre la vie et la nuit
c'est ce lien à l'autre qui nous
accompagne depuis notre naissance et qui
est notre oxygène alors on a besoin
évidemment de cet oxygène pour respirer
on a besoin de ce lien pour se sentir
vivant et se sentir exister le bébé dès
qu'il sort du ventre de sa mère il a
besoin d'être tenus d'être contenu
d'être choyé d'être bercé d'être nourris
et ça continue tout au long de notre vie
c'est le même lien qui se transforme
tout au long tout au long de notre vie
et plus on gagne en âge plus on revient
peut-être à ses besoins fondamentaux du
nourrisson où on n'entend pas bien on a
peur on est angoissé on n'a plus besoin
de l'autre besoin de toucher d'être
caressé d'être regardée et salé les
tablettes et autres et autres réseaux
sociaux n'y parviennent bien sûr que non
alors évidemment c'est mieux que rien
d'avoir un contact par par skype que
rien du tout mais on le voit bien moi je
les bus avec avec ma mère je l'appelais
par skype eu tous les deux trois jours
mais ça lui disait rien elle entendait
une voile savait pas d'où ça venait elle
reconnaissait à peine qui s'est elle
regarder tous les côtés pour savoir d'où
venait cette voie enfin bon ça n'avait
pas beaucoup de sens alors que juste
prendre la main de l'autre même sans
parler et avoir ce contact corporel
c'est beaucoup plus important que les
paroles échangées c'est pour ça que vous
l'avez fait ce témoignage pour faire
prendre conscience des traumatismes
qu'on allait qu'on allait engendrer en
continuant à appliquer ce genre d'un
café tout à fait parce qu'a priori j'ai
pas de raison de parler des expériences
intimes comme ça devant à devant un
grand public mais ça m'a paru important
de le faire pour carnet un peu ce
ce discours autour de la nécessité de
réformer
cette scène ses relations et cet accueil
auprès des prêts des personnes âgées et
heureusement
j'espère y avoir un petit peu contribué
à ma manière large diriez vous que tout
a changé aujourd'hui depuis le 13 avril
c'est vrai que le président de la
république a expliqué qu'on pouvait
organiser une présence des familles
aussi bien dans les ehpad quel hôpital
est-ce que vous avez un tir peu de
retours des tables louis absolument ça
ça a été très vite parce que les
familles je peux vous dire qu'ils ont
entendu le message pouvait pas savoir le
nombre de messages de famille que j'ai
reçus après mon témoignage par par mail
par par lettre par messages
téléphoniques des gens en larmes au
téléphone qu'ils aiment et aidez nous
aidez nous on vit une situation
insupportable avec avec nos parents et
là évidemment les familles aient entendu
ce message ils ont massivement était
dans l'est dans les ehpad et dans les
maisons de retraite pour exercer ce
droit de visite vis-à-vis de leurs de
leurs parents vous disiez tout à l'heure
que être là jusqu'au bout relevait de la
civilisation de l'humanité que ces
règles d'une certaine façon pouvait
s'apparenter à une forme de barbarie et
ça ça remonte on voit bien le droit à
une sépulture très très loin dans
l'histoire on pense à antigone bien sûr
est ce que est ce qu'on peut s'en
remettre parce qu'il ya des familles qui
n'auront pas pu
profiter de ces nouvelles règles moins
drastiques quelle blessure psychique et
demeure quel traumatisme
il ya un traumatisme à gagne blessure a
beaucoup en ont témoigné auprès de moi
je pense que ce traumatisme peut se
sucrer que ces blessures peuvent
dépenser fini justement quelque chose de
civiliser s'organise autour du deuil
autour de la disparition lorsque nous
sortirons de ce confinement il est
évidemment toujours possible d'organiser
des cérémonies des soirées où on parlera
du mort où on échangera des lettres des
hommages des mots des photos des vidéos
enfin bon tout ce qu'on tout ce qu'on
peut faire autour de ça et où surtout le
gros le groupe familial et amical pour à
se resserrer et éprouvée ensemble autour
de cette disparition parce qu'au fond
c'est ça le plus important dans les
rituels collectifs c'est d'éprouver
ensemble c'est cette résonance
émotionnelle entre toutes les personnes
qui ont connu le défunt et qui participe
à son départ parfois c'est très joyeux
il ya beaucoup de rires qui circule
aussi parce qu'on évoque les on évoque
les bons souvenirs c'est pas forcément
quelque chose de tragique mais en tout
cas c'est cette résonance très
particulière que le groupe peut
ressentir à ce moment là il ya aussi des
images de la catastrophe qui ont été
montrées les cercueils entreposés à
rungis en france 1 faute de place dans
les crématoriums d'autres dans des
phocéens qui ont été creusés pour la
circonstance je pense aux images qu'on a
pu voir dans l'île du port de new york
il faut les montrer ces images ou pas
écoutez c'est la réalité c'est un peu
moi ça m'évoque des images de guerre
quand on voit des cada au fond des
fosses communes
malheureusement les choses se sont
passées comme ça on peut pas se voiler
la face ces choses-là on ont existé que
personne n'en est vraiment responsable
cette épidémie a été tellement ravageuse
sur tous les plans sur le plan de la
mortalité sur le plan psychique que ça
nous a conduit à ce type de à ce type
d'actes voilà il faut en prendre acte
mais surtout il faut pouvoir le dépasser
encore une fois en mettant des décomptes
rituel des contres attitude par rapport
à ce qui s'est passé il ya les enfants
les enfants face à un deuil la perte
d'un grand parent face à une épidémie
imprévisible comment faire avec les
enfants qu'est ce qu'on doit leur dire
pour pour leur faire accepter parfois un
dock très difficile dans lequel peut se
mêler aussi de la culpabilité
alors si cia la culpabilité c'est
difficile de pas de pâles transmettre
parce que les enfants le sens autun dans
la façon dont on leur parle donc j'ai
avec le premier travail des adultes
c'est déjà de se débarrasser de cette
culpabilité qui ne sert à rien il il n'y
a pas à se sentir coupables qu on y est
on y est pour rien par rapport à cette
histoire chacun a fait du mieux qu'il a
pu et ça c'est important déjà de
l'intégrer ensuite et bien aux enfants
les enfants là pour eux la mort ça fait
aussi partie de l'existence on est bébé
on devient adulte on devient une
personne âgée ces personnes âgées vont
mourir à un moment ou un autre et les
enfants dans une conscience très précoce
de cela même s'ils se figurent pas
exactement ce qu'est ce qu'est la mort
on peut pas les protéger de ça on peut
simplement leur rappeler à quel point
cette personne qui n'est plus elle
existe encore dans notre esprit elle
existe dans notre conscience elle et
elle peut exister dans nos conversations
que ça fait pas de mal d'en parler et on
peut évoquer avec eux tout ce qui a été
important pour ces personnes qui ont
vécu un moment et une vie plus
aujourd'hui si ces morts aujourd'hui ils
n'ont pas de visage mis à part les
personnalités connues dont on montre les
visages pense assez musicien manu
dibango certains élus aussi patrick
devedjian est ce que ces visages là
peuvent incarner tous les autres ou à un
moment donné il faudra démontrer les
sites et écrire leur nom comme on fait
voilà des cérémonies du souvenir
des mémorial pour les victimes pour les
victimes de guerre aussi écouté je ne
suis pas sûr que une épidémie soit à ce
niveau sur le plan de jeu veut dire au
niveau d'une guerre au niveau d'une
catastrophe naturelle au niveau d' acte
terroriste par exemple qui ont à voir
vraiment avec la ddt la nation en tant
que tel dans son dans son éthique dans
un moral dans sa construction là on a
affaire à quelque chose d'un petit peu
naturel qui est une maladie qui a pris
cette forme là je pense que pour ce
qu'il en est du deuil et la disparition
en dehors de ces personnes qui sont
connues ça à voir avec l'intimité de
chaque famille ces personnels ont un nom
elles ont un visage elles ont une
histoire je pense que c'est à chaque
famille de transmettre à l'intérieur du
groupe tous les éléments qui concerne le
mort toutes ces images toutes ces photos
tous et tous ces souvenirs qu'on peut
avoir par rapport à lui voilà comme ça
je vous dirais je suis pas sûr que ces
appartiennent à notre identité
collective aura et l'aja parle aux
cliniciens que vous êtes beaucoup pas
réparé après oui il y aura beaucoup à
réparer parce que on a vécu un
traumatisme on est encore dans le
traumatisme à l'heure actuelle un
traumatisme c'est comme quand on prend
un coup sur la tête et qu'on ne s'y
attend pas et que ça vous fait changer
votre vie à 180° d'une seconde à l'autre
quasiment et si c'est ce qui c'est passé
pour nous tout ça a été une vraie
effraction pacifique avec tous les
effets que ça peut avoir alors ce qu'on
sait des traumatismes c'est que sur le
moment on réagit et parfois ont réagi
avec beaucoup de force et beaucoup de
vitalité justement pour ne pas se
laisser emporter et que l'on met en
place toutes les défenses personnels qui
sont très actives et très utile pour
pouvoir réagir contre le traumatisme et
puis vient le post traumatique qui va
venir à mon avis dans les semaines qui
viennent ou l'ajustement peut-être que
la vie va reprendre un cours plus normal
les enfants vont retourner à l'école etc
il ya quelque chose de plus habituel qui
va se mettre en place et là il va
falloir digérer tout ce qui nous est
arrivé il va falloir le leur prendre
leur pensée qu'est ce que ça a changé
pour nous qu est ce que ça va changer
dans notre vie future est ce que ça nous
fait revoir un certain nombre de valeurs
un certain nombre de valeurs collectives
de valeurs familiales de balleure
conjugales donc par rapport à soi aussi
la personne dont on se projette dans
l'avenir mettre en oeuvre les conditions
d'une résidence collective vous avez un
début de réponse qu'est ce que ça va
changer qu'est-ce que ça va changer en
ou
peut-être dans un rapport de filiation
dans les relations intrafamiliales
le jour d'après sur ces questions si
sensible de la mort ça ressemble à quoi
écoutez je crois que toutes les familles
ont vécu quelque chose à quoi elles
n'étaient pas habitués qui est un
resserrement des liens familiaux qui est
quelque chose qui a donné une autre
texture a
ressenti des liens dans les couples et à
l'intérieur des familles je vous dirai
pour le meilleur et pour le pire le
meilleur c'est que il s'est recréé dans
beaucoup de familles une espèce de cocon
dans lesquels on a appris les liens les
liens affectifs dans lesquels les
parents ont eu une autre un autre regard
sur leurs enfants et les enfants sur
leurs parents et des conjoints dans le
couple le pire c'est que il ya eu aussi
évidemment beaucoup de beaucoup
d'intrication
émotionnel des uns par rapport aux
autres beaucoup d'empiétement des uns
sur les autres c'est tous ces
éléments-là ces éléments à la fois
constructif et ses éléments beaucoup
plus destructeur qui vont être un
reprendre après est ce que est ce que
les coudes en tenir ou pas est ce qu'on
va faire plus de bébés enfin tout ça
vous dit si jamais une nouvelle et et
d'épidémies de cet ordre d'une autre ne
recommençons pas les erreurs du début de
confinement ça c'est ce que vous envoyez
un message surtout pas d'interdiction
non surtout pas surtout pas vis-à-vis
des personnes âgées les premières c'est
vrai que ce sont les plus fragiles c'est
leur équipe c'est elle qui paye le plus
lourd tribut à la maladie mais ces
ruptures qu'on a pu mettre en place
vis-à-vis d'elle sur le plan du
désespoir que ça a généré pour elle et
dans les familles sur le plan la
détérioriation psychique que s'est
entraîné pour elle ben je crois qu'on
est un peu entre charybde et scylla et
qu' il faut pouvoir aussi ménager cet
aspect relationnel merci beaucoup faire
j'ai fait
[Musique]